Next time.
What you will see is something that
was missing from many of the big goal
orientations of many
assignments. What, what is it?
What is the complexity of
the ray tracing algorithm?
Depending on what it depends on the
resolution, the bigger the English,
the longer it takes.
Got It.
It is exponential with respect to the
death at least this implementation is if
you, if you should have to raise,
there is always a branching. Damn,
this is going to be exponential, so we
have taken into consideration resolution.
We have taken into consideration
depth but we haven't taken,
taken into consideration how many
objects there are in the scene and if you
start running the same ray tracer on
huge thing because you don't want to see
spheres, you won't want to do
ray tracing like real men do,
then what you do is you implement
a function that can load.
You try,
we'll measures and then you just grab
a Nice Triangle Mesh and I seen from
somewhere loaded to your ray tracer and
you very excitedly the ray tracer and
you don't get anything
in your whole lifetime.
If you lose something with millions of
and which voltages, not much nowadays. Why
someone else. Yeah, so
fixed. Wrong. That's true.
But why does it take too long?
Because you have to do a lot of
intersections lists. Exactly. So I have,
if I have 1 million objects,
I have to do one minute intersections
every single time. That's too much.
That's just way too much.
So what we can do is that we can
do some kind of space partitioning,
which means that simple
optimizations I can do,
for instance,
I really don't care what is behind me
because I'm going to intersect something
that's in front of me. So whatever is
behind me, I can immediately throw this,
all of those polygons out,
that's immediately half of it.
And if you use smart
tricks and Katie trees,
smart tricks,
smart data structures,
you can go from linear while
in the air one way or objects,
one minute intersections.
So that's linear complexity.
You can go to local rhythmic complexity,
which is amazing because
the logarithm after a point,
it doesn't really increase too much.
And you will learn about techniques
that will make you able to compute this
intersection with like 1 million objects,
with about four or five
intersections of leverage.
Obviously obviously it depends on the
distribution of the triangles and all of
that, but on average you can do it in
four or five intersection instead of one
Lillian, so it's a huge shoot. Speed up.
This is going to be out the next spectrum,
and again it seems that I have been
lying to you all along regarding this as
well because I told you that
are measuring radiants for uh,
than the equation.
Now radiants I cannot really display on
my monitor or what can I display in my
minor RGB values.
So there has to be some transformation
that comes from radios and converted to
RGB in a meaningful way.
This process is called and told that
big and Thomas is going to tell you all
about that thing as well. You can
do it in a number of different ways.
It's happening on the trivial
and the good tone back. They,
it really breathes life
into your rendered images.
Yeah.
Now we haven't talked about filtering.
This is a bit more sophisticated recursive
ray tracing you show you should one
sample through the mid point of the big
source of leucine. You computed this,
you're done with Monte-carlo integration.
We are going to have many samples so we
are going to have a metric that's called
samples for big soul and these samples
will not go through the mid point of the
Pixel.
These are going to go through the surface
of the pixel like random samples over
the surface of the pixel and we are
going to integrate the valiums over the
whole surface.
Now you can do this differently because
you have many samples over the pixel
surface and you can take into
consideration them into consideration the
different ways and you can see
that different filtering method.
This is what we call filtering and
different filtering methods will give you
different results and the interesting
part is that you will get anti aliasing
for free if you do filtering well because
in a ray tracer you will shoot one
race through the mid point of the Pixel.
Your images,
unless they are super high resolution,
they are going to be areas.
The completely straight line
is going to be pixelated.
The edges are going to be pixilated.
What can you do?
Feel things like super sampling.
Let's split one pixel into 400 pixels
for smaller pixels and compute the race
through all of them and leverage.
That's the Vivian method that gives
you anti-aliasing by supercenter,
but this is super expensive.
I mean you have HD resolutions and you
have to bump this up by even four times
too much. There's better solutions.
You can get this for free.
You global elimination
if you do feel different,
so this is what filtering is about.
Domestic is also going to talk,
this is not one retro is the next
three lectures it's going to talk about
participate in media.
What is this about? Well,
in our simulations so far we have taken
into consideration that race of flight
only bounce off of surfaces, but in
real life there's not only surfaces,
there's volumes that smoke haze.
Many of these effects where array of light
can not really hit an object but just
small and get scattered.
And if you do your simulation in a way
that it supports such participate in
medium,
then you can get volume costs
and that's amazing because I just have
shown you the ring and whatever else kind
of costings and we'll look at,
you will think of those as as some two
d things that I see it on the table,
this diffuse material that that
diffuses this rate inspect to me.
So you would think that sticks and
shadows are playing are they are two deep
things but they are in fact volumes.
So the shallows exist not only
the plane but they have the volume
because the,
the set of points that are extracted from
the light source or not on the plane,
they are in three d.
Yeah
and you can get volumetric castex and
volume shuttles with participating in
media media because
there will be immediate,
immediate in terror of
which light can scatter.
So therefore you will
see these boundaries.
You can also get God rays.
Beautiful,
phenomenal in curriculum in that nature.
If you compute participating,
okay.
You can also get something like this.
This is an actual photograph just to make
sure that you see the difference that
the,
the first raid is traversing the air
or vacuum and the next ones haven't
participated in Edo which can give you
discipline, this scattering effect.
And another example of God rays while
apparently we have this do not disturb.
Okay
piece of paper. So there is some lacks
render and then going on in this room,
you better not enter who
knows what you will see
and you can get,
not necessarily suck pronounced effects,
but the more subtle effect that you can,
you can feel that there is some,
he's in this image but it's,
it's not super.
Yeah.
Now we don't stop there because
don't just think of of
smoke and atmosphere.
You can just look at your own skin if
you would like to see some participating
helium.
Now this is a phenomenon he called
subsurface scattering and this means that
some of the things that you
would think our objects are, uh,
surfaces are in fact volumes.
This is your skin. For instance,
light goes through your
skin portion of light.
And we don't simulate that because
when we hit the surface of the object,
we though you bet.
And if we write this innovation that
makes us evil to go inside of these
objects,
then we have a simulation with subsurface
scattering and we kind of come from
beautiful,
beautiful effects like this.
These are some simulations.
So for instance,
on the left side you can see probably
in the marble there's subsurface
scattering in marbles.
It seems heavily exaggerated to
me or either there is a really,
really strong that lighting,
but this is not a surface anymore.
You can see the nose of the lady light.
Lots of softer radiants
actually gets the food to those.
This is one more example.
This is not so pronounced and this is,
this is not so exaggerated,
but you can see this.
J Dragon clearly has some subsurface
scattering who kept the home tickling same
parts like the end of the tail.
You can see that it's much lighter and
this is because some of the light is
going through it and the
optical [inaudible] thick
parts like the body of the
dragon have less subsurface scattering.
So you can see that this is a bit darker.
It's a beautiful phenomenon.
And we can also see lead this.
I look at,
look at this one.
Absolutely amazing that
doesn't this look amazing.
This is incredibly awesome.
We can ride computer programs that
can compute this reasonable amount.
So absolutely beautiful phenomenon.
I still kept this as well.
This is a fractal. It's subsurface
scattering. I mean, how,
how cool can someone get it's
fractals and subsurface galleries.
It's like two of the best
foods mixed together. It's is,
it has to be something else.
And another example of
a beautiful jade dragon
with just a bit of subsurface scattering.
Yeah.
So that's going to be it for today
and there's going to be the next three
lectures with us.
These are all the exciting things that
are going to be discussed and that we
will complete the Monte Carlo integration.
I will tell you how I lied to you exactly.
And how do you use mathematics to see
from these lies and that maybe the right,
our global illumination program.
Thank you.